ايضا في العوده الى الاماكن التي تمكنت
صواريخ المقاومه من تجاوز القبه الحديديه
واصابتها بشكل مباشر كان هناك حديث عن
اصابه مباشره لمنزل في السير واستيرات
وهناك حديث عن صاروخ سقط وسط اسرائيل
شاهدنا بعض الصور وايضا حديث عن خمسه
اصابات حتى اللحظه
دعيني فقط اشير الى النقطه التي تحدثت
عنها مياده المعركه الاعلاميه في مثل هذه
الاحداث عند عندما تكون هناك مواجهه
عسكريه او امنيه لا تقر ربما دراوه عما
يحدث على الارض هناك اعلام موجه من قبل
الجانب الاسرائيلي ويحسبون ربما كل كلمه
لذلك
يحاولون طيله الوقت التركيز على قضيه
التمييز والفصل بين الفصائل المقاومه
عندما يريدون ذلك عندما تقع مصلحتهم في
هذا السياق لذلك نسمع حتى هذه اللحظه بان
الاستهداف هو فقط لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
لكن لو عدنا للاسبوع الماضي فقط عندما
ايضا اطلقت الجهاد الاسلامي الصواريخ
باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه
بعد استشهاد الاسير خضر عدنان في السجون
السجون الاحتلال اسرائيل مباشره حملت حركه
حماس المسؤوليه عن اطلاق هذه الصواريخ رغم
انها قالت بان حركه الجهاد الاسلامي هي من
قامت باطلاق الصواريخ وبالتالي المعركه
الاعلاميه هنا لا تقل كما ذكرت دراوه او
لها اهميه كبيره بالنسبه
للجانبين بطبيعه الحال اسرائيل منذ يوم
امس ترصد كل كلمه وكل حرف
تخرج عن اي مسؤول فلسطيني لا سيما قاده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في محاوله لمتابعه
الردود الفلسطينيه لاسيما في فتره الترقب
والانتظار للرد الفلسطيني على مستوى قضيه
القبه الحديديه هذه المنظومه عمليا هي
منظومه تعمل على اساس رصد الصواريخ
بنظام الرادار
وبالعاده تنجح بحسب معطيات للجيش
الاسرائيلي ب 95% لرصد حركه هذه الصواريخ
قبل ان
اعتراضها لكنها تقوم على اعتراض الصواريخ
التي قد تسقط في مناطق ماهوله هذه
الصواريخ هذه المنظومه لا تعمل عندما تكون
الصواريخ موجهه لمناطق غير ماهوله
وبالتالي مثلا على سبيل المثال عندما يتم
توجيه هذه الصواريخ اللي منطقه الناقب
الغربي لا تدوي صافرات الانذار عند القرى
الفلسطينيه البدويه لماذا لان اسرائيل لا
تعترف بهذه القرى ولا تضعها على الخارطه
وعلى منظومه الرادار وبالتالي قد تكون
الاصابات هناك اكثر في الاسبوع الماضي
عندما كان هناك اطلاق لاكثر من 100 صاروخ
تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد عده ايام عن
انه كان هناك خلل تقني في هذه المنظومه
بحيث تراجع صدى الصواريخ الى نسبه 90% في
المناطق الماهوله وبالتالي هناك مش دائما
قائم من عشره الى خمسه بالمئه لعدم صد هذه
الصواريخ تحديدا عندما تاتي هذه الصواريخ
على شكل رشقات متتاليه من الجانب
الفلسطيني من قبل حركات المقاومه عندها
يحدث نوع من الارباك بالنسبه لمنظومه
الرادار ولمنظومه القبه الحديديه لصد
الصواريخ قريبه المدى وبالتالي قد تسقط
بين الحين والاخر هذه الصواريخ في مواقع
ماهوله وقد شهدنا ذلك في المعركه السابقه
وفي معارك عده جولات قتاليه سابقه وربما
بعد عاده هذه المعارك وبعد هذه الحروب
والعدوان الذي تشنه اسرائيل على غزه نرى
بعدها بفتره كل الشكاوى للمطالبه بتعويضات
عن الاضرار من قبل الاسرائيليين وهذا يدلل
حجم هذه الشكاوى تدلل على حجم الاضرار
التي تسببها ب الحال هذه القذائف وهذه
الصواريخ وان كان خلال المعركه لا يتم
التطرق الى ذلك من منطلق ربما اعلامي كما
ذكرت قبل قليل وبالتالي تكون هناك اصابات
لمباني لمركبات في الشوارع لكن الهامش
يعتبر ضيق الا اذا كان هناك استهداف
لمناطق مفتوحه لا يتم تفعيل منظومه القبه
الحديديه او كما ذكرت يحدث هناك بعض
الارباك لمنظومه الرادار فيما اذا اطلقت
هذه الصواريخ على شكل
والكثيف من الرشقات عندها لا يتم الرصد
وجهه هذه الصواريخ بشكل
محدد لذلك عاده ربما يكون نجاح هذه
المنظومه اكثر عندما يتم اطلاق الصواريخ
في مراحل مختلفه في الاونه الاخيره تم
تعزيز بطبيعه الحال هذه المنظومه في محيط
غزه في البلدات الحدوديه في غلاف غزه في
البلدات الاخرى ولكن ايضا في منطقه تل
ابيب عندما تكون هناك اي توقعات لمواجهه
يتم اعاده
وضع هذه المنظومه في اماكن مختلفه تغيير
الاماكن تحديدا في المناطق التي يتوقع
فيها الجانب الاسرائيلي ان تصل اليها هذه
الصواريخ او هذه المنظومه الدفاعيه براينا
قبل قليل كيف تم صد احد الصواريخ التي
بالفعل وصلت الى مدينه تل ابيب باسرائيل
تعول كثيرا على هذه المنظومه ودائما ما
تكون هناك اسئله ماذا كان سيحدث في هذا
الطرف لو لم تكن هناك مثل هذه المنظومه
لصد الصواريخ قريبه المدى مياده لذلك حتى
الان نتحدث عن اكثر من
100 صاروخ في الساعه الاخيره